hi guys I'm back with one another trick
with MHA so in imagine we can do another
process nurse background subtraction and
I will describe the process and why it
is important so let me open one image so
this image is a movie of calcium imaging
it's a life imaging so in this cases
whatever you can see in grey is your
signal so here if I apply a duty you can
see here is my signal
but the problem is yet the background is
so much that the signal is not visible
properly so in order to enhance the
signal we can reduce the background such
that we can see the signal let's just
keep this image aside and we will
process another image using the
background subtraction algorithm this is
the same image and then what I will do
is go to the process and there is
substract background algorithm in this
substract background algorithm you can
enable the preview option and you can
change the rolling ball radius in a
moment I would explain what is rolling
ball radius for example you can change
it to 80 you can change it to 50 as well
and you would see the difference so a
good option is to keep it at 80 in for
this image once you apply it you take a
little while for a peep for applying
this change and it is done now so now if
I play the movie side by side you can
see after background obstruction the
signal is enhanced than the background
so what just happened in this background
subtraction algorithm so background
obstruction algorithm uses a rolling
ball radius
so imagine this rape pixel is the pixel
around it there is a ball this rolling
ball radius could be variable you can
change the rolling ball radius what this
algorithm will do is take the average
run of all those pixels surrounding that
particular red pixel in this radius of
this blue area and it would take the
average and substract in from each pixel
for example here is a image kind of a
pixelated image at high zoom so after a
background obstruction you can see the
image would become somewhat like this so
the background is reduced and the signal
is enhanced and this kind of algorithm
could be very important for processing
live imaging data for processing for
further processing of this data this
kind of bad background imaging the
background obstruction is important I
hope you enjoyed my video if you like my
video give it a big thumbs up don't
forget to share like and subscribe thank
you